thank you so much i can be very brief
because this is a very defining moment
and a very good day for europe today
um i warmly congratulate president
zielenski
president sandu president zura bishwili
all three countries are part of our
european family we've never let any
doubt about that and today's historic
decision by leaders confirms that
it grants all three the perspective of
eu accession
and it lays down the path ahead
i think this is a moment of great
satisfaction and i'm very pleased with
the leaders endorsement of our opinions
there can be no better sign of hope for
the citizens of ukraine moldova and
georgia in these troubled times
of course the countries all have to do
homework before moving to the next stage
of the accession process
but i am convinced that they will all
move as swiftly as possible and work as
hard as possible to implement the
necessary reforms
not just because they are required to
move ahead in the european accession
path
but first and foremost
because these reforms are good for the
countries good for the democracy
because it strengthens the
competitiveness of all three countries
and ultimately they are good for the
citizens
let me stress that
mr president you have the floor thank
you very much well everything's been
said
i just wanted to stress
just how important this historic moment
is in the context we're living through
right now a war
decided on by russia
against ukraine and its people on
ukraine's soil
a week ago in kiev went together with
olaf schultz mario draghi from germany
in italy
and klasianis from romania
we
took this commitment
to
get an agreement to give ukraine
candidate status took seat of the
european union
which is the starter of a road map
we knew it all depended on the process
and over the last week
we have made some giant strides forward
thanks to work done by the commission
first of all
they've proposed a method on
the basis
of work done together with ukraine
and then together with president
michelle
consensus has been forged unanimity
indeed between
the members of a council
and
we saw this with president zalensky a
very strong message a coherent message
right from day one of the conflict
europe's been reacting quickly this is
historic we've been united
first with sanctions two days afterwards
then the macroeconomic and military
support financial support we prior to
ukraine and now by this political
gesture
so i think this strong
united europe
has been up to the task